i think from first principles all of the
components are there to engineer
intimate experiences in the meta verse
or in in the in the cyberspace
and
so to me it's
it i don't see anything profoundly
unique to the physical experience like i
don't understand but then why are you
saying there's a loss there
no i'm just sad because i won't oh it's
a loss for me personally because uh it
the the world but you do think there's
something unique in the physical
experience for me because i was raised
with it oh yeah yeah so whatever any so
anything you're raised with you fall in
love with like people in this country
came up with baseball i was raised in
the soviet union i don't understand
baseball i get i like it but i don't
love it the way americans love it
um it's because a lot of times they went
to to to baseball games with their
father and then there's that family
connection there's a young kid
dreaming about i don't know
um
becoming an
mlb player himself i don't know
something like that but that that's what
you're raised with obviously is really
important but i mean fundamentally to
the human experience
listen we're doing this podcast in
person so clearly i i still value it but
but it's true if this were obviously
through a screen we all agree that's not
the same yeah that's not the same but if
this were some you know we had contact
lenses on and like yeah maybe neuralink
you know play maybe again forget again
this is all the the devices even if it's
as cool as a contact lens that's all old
school yeah once you have the brain
machine interface
it'll just be projection um
it'll take over my visual cortex my
visual cortex will get put into a
virtual room and so will yours so we
will see we will hear really hear and
see as if where you won't have any masks
no vr mask needed and at that point it
really will feel like you'll forget
you'll see we'll read together and
physically or not you won't even it'd be
so unimportant you won't even remember
and you're right this is one of those
shits in society that changes everything
but romantically people still need to be
together that there's a whole set of
like physical things
with uh relationship that are needed you
know like like what like success
sex but also just like that there's
pheromones like there's the the physical
touch is such a that's like music it's
such a deeply primitive
part of us the the what physical touch
with a romantic partner does that i
think that so i'm sure there'll be a
whole whole wave of people who their new
thing is that you know you're
romantically involved people you're
never actually in person with but and
i'm sure there'll be things where you
can actually smell what's in the room
and you can yeah and touch yeah but i
think that'll be one of the last things
to go i think there'll be there's
something
that to me seems like something that'll
be um it'd be a while before people feel
like there's nothing lost by not being
invisible it's it's very difficult to
replicate the human interaction although
sex also again you could
not to get too like weird but you could
have a thing where you you're basically
um you know or you know you're let's
just do a massage because it's less like
awkward but like you someone you know
everyone is still imagining sex so a
masseuse could massage
a
fake body and you could feel whatever's
happening
right so you're lying down in your
apartment alone but you're feeling a
full they'll be the new like youtube or
like streaming whereas one masseuse
massaging one body but like a thousand
people are experiencing exactly right
now think about it right now you know
what taylor swift doesn't play for one
person has to go around and every one of
her fans just to go play for or a book
right you do it and it goes everywhere
so it'll be the same idea
you